et à l'issue de ce rassemblement
emmanuel macron a réuni ses ministres
autour d'un conseil de défense des
mesures pourraient être annoncées dans
la foulée pour en débattre nous sommes
en direct avec jean mi cia membre du
bureau national du rassemblement
national bonsoir tout ça faisait nous
sommes également avec françois cocq
essayiste et ancien orateurs france
insoumise bonsoir merci à tous les deux
d'être d'accepter d'avoir d'être en
direct sur rt france pour débattre tout
d'abord une question avoue françois cocq
votre réaction sur sur ce rassemblement
l'unité de la nation c'est important
unité nos nations et bien évidemment
décisives mais ce qui ressort de ce
rassemblement vous savez après le grand
mouvement charlie où ils étaient deux
nations étaient été proclamée mais qui
s'est fait dans un climat de sidération
là les gens étaient beaucoup plus
déterminés il me semble et se projeter
déjà dans la suite ils ont envie de
mettre un coup d'arrêt désormais à tout
cela que les mots soient posées
explicitement sur ce qu'est l'islamisme
c'est à dire l'islam politique qui
s'insinue aujourd'hui dans la société et
qui va jusqu'à son coeur jusqu'à
l'endroit où l'on forme les citoyens
c'est à dire jusqu'au jusqu'au coeur de
l'école et ils n'ont plus envie de
laisser passer quoi que ce soit les gens
sont désormais résolus à agir et je
crois que c'est ça l'état d'esprit
importants qui se dégage est aujourd'hui
de la place de la république
et pour ce faire il faut bien sûr
l'unité de la nation mais on a vu que
notre pays s'est beaucoup divisés sur
ces questions là et peut-être que plus
que jamais justement nous sommes dans
l'un de ces moments de refondation
républicaine où il nous faudra nous
rassembler sur ce qu'est la nation à
savoir un contrat politique passée entre
toutes entre tout laisse toutes les
citoyennes et tous les citoyens un
contrat politique qui met au coeur un
principe d'organisation sociale et
politique
la laïcité jean messi à l'unité de la
nation effectivement on l'avait vu alors
des attentats de charlie hebdo est ce
que ça suffit aujourd'hui de se
rassembler d'ailleurs est-ce que le
rassemblement national et à participer
pas que je sache en tout cas moi je n'y
étais pas ça veut pas dire que je suis
pas favorable évidemment à l'unité de la
nation mais le problème si vous voulez
c'est que au delà des manifestations et
des discours grandiloquents sûr
la laïcité etc enfin l'ennemi qui nous
attaquent aujourd'hui ils nous attaquent
est déjà hier et avant-hier et
effectivement nous retrouvons
aujourd'hui à la nasa la république des
courants politiques comme le courant qui
gouverne la france c'est à dire le
courant progressiste entre guillemets
ainsi que europe écologie les verts sans
parler de la france insoumis styles sont
autant de courants finalement qui ont
favorisé une immigration de masse
l'islamisation et l'islamisme en bout de
chaîne le terrorisme donc si vous voulez
ce sont des gens qui ont manifesté très
souvent aux côtés des islamistes on se
souvient de cette manifestation abjecte
où vous aviez des petites filles voilées
qui portait des étoiles de david aux
côtés de ces de la sénatrice esther
benbassa d'europe écologie les verts et
de représentants du courant indigéniste
de la france a soumis ce qui est
aujourd'hui le courant majoritaire
ces gens là doivent avoir la décence
aujourd'hui ne pas aller manifester
contre ce qu'ils ont directement ou
indirectement soutenu pu voir appeler de
leurs voeux pendant des années moi je
veux bien qu'on parle de l'unité de la
nation
mais à un moment si vous voulez il faut
aussi prendre les responsabilités et
désigner à la fois les responsables et
les coupables du capharnaüm identitaires
et sécuritaires dans lequel et est
aujourd'hui la france donc
manifester oui cela l'était oui mais je
crois que la guerre contre le terrorisme
qui a été déclarée il ya plusieurs
années quand on mène une guerre dans une
guerre on se bat et on se bat pas avec
des bougies des nounours des bisous
bisous et des lâchers de ballons si vous
voulez un moment il faut prendre les
mesures contre les fichiers s
radicaliser qu'il soit doré doré qu'ils
soient étrangers ou clandestins il faut
il faut les mettre dehors il faut fermer
les mosquées radical il faut prendre le
problème de cet islamisme qui gangrène
notre pays à bras le corps
l'autre pays est aujourd'hui face à une
menace de la montée en puissance d'un
totalitarisme mortifère et le
gouvernement doit enfin agir pour mettre
fin à ces massacres de français nous
avons eu je le rappelle deux attentats
en quinze jours ça suffit
réponse françois cocq réaction également
à la loi sur le séparatisme
qui a qui a mis deux ans quand même à
sortir je le rappelle le gouvernement
maintenant vous allez vitesse que est-ce
que c'est trop tard
écoutez je n'ai pas la même approche un
peu politicienne que celle de monsieur
mais cia et ce qui est important
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas ce que
racontent les parties ou ce qu'ils ont
raconté hier il s'est passé un événement
important et d'une certaine façon
fondateur c'est que les gens aient enfin
compris dans ce pays que la question de
l'islam politique la question donc de
l'islamisme et donc de sa de sa
dimension djihadistes qui est une part
de l'islamisme mais de l'islamisme en
général n'était pas une question qui
était un à côté de l'islam
c'est une question qui concerne aussi
l'islam est l'islam doit traiter cette
question qui se passe en son sein et le
propos du du grand recteur de la grande
mosquée de paris vendredi soir qu'ils
allaient en ce sens qui disait nous ne
pouvons plus nous suffire de
condamnations toutes les mosquées
doivent agir c'est une rupture là dedans
et une rupture importante pour laquelle
je plaide vous savez tout cela va
complètement à contre-courant de la loi
sur le séparatisme de monsieur macro que
dit monsieur m'apprend monsieur macron
s'assoit sur la laïcité en nous disant
que c'est un amour et public de former
les imams
autrement dit on va aller remettre le
doit à m le temporel qui va aller se
mêler du spirituel
et que font les islamistes ils veulent
justement que le spirituel passe sous la
queue le temporel passe sous la coupe du
spirituel
autrement dit finalement monsieur macro
apporte de l'eau au moulin des des
islamistes eh bien il faut rompre avec
tout ça il faut que l'islam près que le
problème qui existe en son sein et pour
le reste la république elle ne doit pas
céder d'un iota doit être ferme sur ses
positions et plus déterminé encore que
jamais et revendicative comme elle doit
l'être aujourd'hui à l'école alors on
entend aujourd'hui effectivement ce
besoin de fermeté au delà des mots m au
t1 mais cia ce soir il ya un conseil de
défense présidée par emmanuel macron il
devrait peut-être annoncé des mesures
notamment sur la sécurité de l'école
au delà des démos que que doit-on
attendre quelles mesures sont urgentes
selon vous alors que doit-on attendre de
la part des gouvernements pas grand
chose hélas je suis un peu surpris que
monsieur coque ne partage pas mon
analyse lui qui a été le fer de lance au
sein de la france insoumise quand il y
était de la lutte contre l'islam radical
et notamment à travers les
comité hébert et l'étude de l'entrisme
islamistes dans les syndicats
je croque monsieur françois cocq
auxquels je rends hommage pour sa
lucidité dans un courant politique qui
ne l'est plus hélas je crois qu'on peut
trouver quand même un accord pour dire
que healy a aujourd'hui un ennemi qui
nous attaquent frontalement juste
pendant très longtemps cet ennemi à
avancer en faisant effectivement de
l'entrisme de manière un peu subreptice
aujourd'hui et depuis quelques années
ces attaques
ces massacres ces tueries augmentent il
faut maintenant sous les responsabiliser
les gens les responsabiliser les
pouvoirs publics par exemple ce réfugié
tchétchène qui est entré à qui on a
donné un droit d'asile je rappelle que
la pologne à laquelle il avait demandé
un droit d'asile a refusé de lui donner
la france avait refusé dans un premier
temps la cour de cassation a octroyé
l'asile à ce tchétchène
il faut faire à l'audit de l'ofpra qui
est l'organisme qui accorde les titres
déchets jour faire un moratoire d'au
moins 2 ans sur toutes les demandes
d'asile qui sont octroyés à l'exception
d'une infime partie
il faut responsable qui elle qui a
décidé de faire rentrer cette personne
sur notre territoire
je crois qu'aujourd'hui il faut qu'on a
on arrête cette espèce d'anonymat si
vous voulez de l'invasion migratoire à
laquelle est soumise la france personne
n'est responsable de rien des gens
arrivent chez nous par dizaines voire
par centaines de milliers et il faut
évidemment arrêter l'immigration qui
fait le lit si vous voulez du
séparatisme
on peut pas le gouvernement peut pas
nous expliquer qui va lutter contre le
séparatisme et outre la limite que
monsieur kokam il ya un instant et à
laquelle je souscris à savoir la
formation des imams et c'est honteux pas
non plus continuer à ouvrir grandes les
vannes de l'immigration puisque cette
immigration nourrit le séparatisme
puisqu'elle est principalement
musulmanes donc à un moment si vous
voulez il faut prendre la chaîne causale
dans son ensemble depuis sa génèse
jusqu'à sa conséquence la plus
terrifiante analysé et décortiqué et
diagnostiquer le problème pour pouvoir
se donner les moyens d'apporter des
mesures efficaces
or si on ne traite que la superficie
épidermique du phénomène c'est à dire
simplement une attaque et on va faire de
la cosmétique et bien c'est se condamner
à revoir les mêmes scènes atroces et
bien serait
étaient dans les rues de france et dans
nos écoles et dans le collège françois 4
jean michel blanquer ce matin a dit que
ce professeur avait reçu le soutien de
sa hiérarchie
est ce que vous pensez qu'il n'y a pas
eu des failles néanmoins dans la
protection de ce professeur dans le
renseignement peut-être puisqu'on sait
maintenant que le père de famille
fréquentait aussi un prédicateur assez
connu vous pensez que ça aurait pu être
évité il ya deux dimensions
il ya un problème et qui est
structurelle aujourd'hui dans
l'éducation nationale depuis que depuis
quelques années nous avons introduit
nous avons introduit nous subissons une
vision managériale qui s'imposent dans
les établissements où de petits
chefaillons qui sont érigés en chef
d'établissement essaie de faire le moins
de vagues possibles et donc nous
remontent absolument rien de ce qui se
passe dans les établissements et on le
voit aujourd'hui notamment sur la crise
qu vie par exemple où tout est toute la
poussière et mises sous le tapis de la
même manière et qu'elle est mise sous le
tapis sur toutes ces questions de
laïcité et sur toutes les atteintes à la
laïcité qui existent ces petits
chefaillons qui remonte tout cela à des
bureaucrates qui veulent faire carrière
et qui pour faire carrière passe tout
sous silence et tout ça est remontée au
près de ministres incompétents
donc nous avons aujourd'hui un problème
dans l'éducation nationale où les
enseignants sont livrés à eux mêmes et
ils font un travail admirable avec les
élèves
ça fait 20 ans vous savez moi que
j'enseigne dans des zones dites violence
et des zones d'éducation prioritaire
aujourd'hui nous faisons sur le travail
les uns les autres je crois que nous ne
cédons ne sait non rien mais nous sommes
pas et politique et puis le deuxième
aspect de votre question c'est bien
évidemment qu'il ya un problème dans le
système de renseignement
enfin on voit quand même que toutes les
informations ont circulé pendant des
jours des jours et des jours et que au
final tout le monde a lancé des alertes
mais rien n'a été fait alors si c'est
pour lancer des alertes dans le vide et
simplement pour se couvrir d'un point de
vue administratif s'en prend les choses
à bras le corps ces non seulement
minimiser le problème mais faire comme
s'il n'existait pas et cela ce n'est
plus aujourd'hui supportable jean
messier a derrière ces questions il faut
renforcer le renseignement peut être
responsabilisés des des personnes 2 2
société civile de toutes ces
administrations éducation nationale
c'est à dire on peut toujours faire ça
bien sûr mais après si vous voulez on ne
luttera pas contre l'idéologie qui qui
comment dirais-je prévaut aussi bien au
sein de l'éducation nationale que dans
les autres institutions
françois cocq rappelé il ya un instant
le mouvement pas de vagues
je rappelle quand même qu'on apprend
aujourd'hui effaré que l'académie à
laquelle appartenait le professeur qui a
été décapitée s'apprêtait à le
sanctionner
précisément pour avoir heurté les élèves
et donc sa part jean michel blanquer
alors je sais je ne suis pas si sûre en
tout cas toute la presse s'est fait
l'écho de cela et en tout cas ça
m'étonne pas puisque ne sais pas c'est
pas un secret si vous voulez que les et
le corps enseignant de manière générale
est traversé par une idéologie qui est
une idéologie très souvent
immigrationniste qui est favorable à une
espèce de colonisation culturelle de la
france et donc à chaque fois que cette
idéologie du vivre ensemble cette
idéologie multiculturalisme va poser
problème
eh bien on va poser une espèce de
couvercle sur la marmite pour éviter que
les choses ressortent et que la réalité
explose au grand jour sauf que le
problème c'est que si on ne permet pas à
cette réalité date de s'exprimer à
travers les canaux officiels et les
cadeaux institutionnels pour pouvoir la
traiter
eh bien elle va exploser comme a explosé
avant-hier par des meurtres des
décapitations d'enseignant donc
effectivement il faut prendre à bras le
corps le problème idéologique
arrêtez de dire que tout tout les toute
immigration tout multiculturalisme est
forcément une bonne chose
il ya un moment il faut stocker et
traiter l'islam radical de la 2de de
façon intraitable voilà et deuxième
chose sur l'islam effectivement jeu là
je rejoins également les propos de
françois cocq le problème il est
également un problème de l'islam a
simplement de l'islamiste veut dire
aujourd'hui la seule religion au nom de
laquelle on tue en france c'est l'islam
on ne tue pas au nom de yahvé on ne tue
pas au nom de jésus dont kylie a
effectivement on en fait un problème
pardon on a beaucoup fait un monsieur
messier à vous le savez oui d'accord
m'appelle à la hausse alors je peux
peut-être mais la france avait elle
avait dieu merci si je puis dire trouver
un subtil équilibre depuis déjà un
siècle on avait renvoyé les églises et
les la religion dans les églises lecture
est aussi et donc contre la société
française et avait trouvé un équilibre
avec ça avec la laïcité avec la loi de
1905 une nouvelle religion est arrivé
sur notre territoire il ya une
quarantaine d'années avec une
exacerbation identitaire et religieuses
sur les vingt dernières années et ça je
suis désolé s'est nourri encore une fois
par l'immigration
aujourd'hui effectivement la personne le
tchétchène qui a tué il n'a pas tué
parce que c'était à l'islamiste qui
étaient rattachés à l'état islamique ou
à des organisations puissantes
c'était justement le cas d'un musulman
en colère des musulmans en colère
pendant l'interview effectivement
l'islam aujourd'hui dans son expression
dans le fait qu'ils soient dominées par
les frères musulmans en france pose un
problème il faut regarder cette réalité
en face et la traiter d'urgence merci
beaucoup
j'en mets cia merci à vous françois cocq
on a vu vous n'étiez pas d'accord mais
on n'a pas le temps malheureusement de
poursuivre ce débat
merci en tout cas d'avoir répondu à nos
questions ce soir sur arte france